(audience applaud and cheer)
- Thank you.
- I like your jacket.
- I did it for you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, well thank
you, dressing up for Christmas.
I love Christmas.
We just did Rockefeller together.
- We did.
- Do you love Christmas?
Do you get into the whole spirit of it?
- Yes, I do.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- Yeah, but you know, when I was a kid,
my stepfather brought home
the first Christmas tree
that I'd ever had 'cause he
had just come into my life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Barry] And it was a little
aluminum foil Christmas tree
with blue balls, and I thought it
was the most beautiful
thing I'd ever seen.
- Oh, I love that.
I love that that memory sticks too.
- [Barry] Yeah.
- How special.
- You never know, see,
people always think you have
to go big and extravagant,
but that little Charlie Brown
moment, that's so beautiful.
I love that.
- [Barry] Yeah, well, we had no money.
- [Kelly] Yeah, no me.
We didn't either.
That's, yeah, so I'm with you.
But your Christmas special
airs tonight on NBC, right?
- Yeah, and it's great.
- [Kelly] Are you excited?
(audience applauds)
I love, I love doing Christmas specials.
Look at all that talent on this stage.
- [Barry] I know, it's great.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Barry] It's a great show.
I was able to put in some of the hits
and the Christmas songs
and you don't even know
which one is coming,
and it's really great.
- [Kelly] Oh, I like that.
- [Barry] Yeah.
- Oh, that's really cool to
do because people always want,
yeah, they always wanna
hear like the hits as well,
so that's really smart.
- Yeah.
- I'm not that smart,
I've never done that.
(Barry laughs)
(audience laugh)
But we heard that they
wouldn't let you have puppies,
that you wanted puppies.
- Well yeah, how did you know that?
- [Kelly] They didn't, I know.
Well, I like puppies.
- Well, you know,
I've got everything man.
It snows on the audience
and there's presents and
there's trees and I thought,
and little children,
the little kids come
running out and Santa Claus,
- Magical.
- [Barry] Everything.
So we had everything,
and I said, gee, wouldn't it
be great if we had like a puppy
for one of the little kids?
- [Kelly] Wouldn't it be great?
Let's bring Barry a puppy.
He didn't get a puppy.
(audience cheers)
(bells jingling)
We've got puppies.
Look at these two cute puppies.
(audience cheering)
(bells jingling)
(Barry laughing)
Oh my God.
Can I hold one?
- Oh my goodness.
- [Mandy] This is Spot.
(Kelly exclaims)
- [Barry] Oh, how old are they?
- Hi.
- [Mandy] And this is Tiny.
- Oh goodness.
- Hello.
- [Barry] Oh my goodness.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- What's your name?
Oh he's little.
- [Kelly] Barry, this is dangerous.
I do not need another dog.
Oh my God, everybody, I should
mention these puppies are
Spot and Tiny from the
Brixies Rescue Center.
And you can find out
how you can adopt them
or their friends by heading to
our shows Instagram stories.
- [Barry] Oh, aren't you the sweetest.
- [Kelly] You're sweet.
Hello.
- I think she recognizes me.
- [Kelly] She did.
She was like, Mandy's her favorite.
- Do you have all my albums?
Mandy is her favorite.
You're trying to get
to my coffee, bruh, no.
I hear that you
actually ended up
breaking Elvis's record in
Vegas with the most live shows, right?
- That was great.
It was an honor.
- [Kelly] That's insane.
- It really was an honor.
- [Kelly] 'Cause anytime
people think of Vegas,
you think of Elvis and
all those live shows.
- [Barry] Yeah.
- And you have trumped him, I like it.
- [Barry] Yeah, and you know,
on that day I sang Hound Dog.
- [Kelly] Oh, did you?
- Me singing Hound Dog.
- [Kelly] Why not?
- And I jiggled around a little bit, like.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I like it.
You gotta jiggle a little, it's Elvis.
Oh, they're like crying.
Do you wanna go run around?
Maybe they wanna run around.
I don't know.
- Should we do it?
- Do you want down or do you want,
do you want down?
- You wanna,
- We're gonna let them down.
- [Barry] You want to go down?
- Let 'em free.
Let 'em be free.
- Okay.
Okay, ready?
- Here we go.
- Ready, run.
- Go have fun.
- Okay.
- They're gonna be peeing
all over this place.
(Kelly laughs)
- Ready pee.
- Yeah, go.
They're like, this is mine, this is mine.
So while they're marking their territory,
oh my God, they're so cute.
I really don't need another dog, Barry.
But I'm thinking about it.
So you,
I've actually celebrated my
birthday a few times on stage.
It just so happens that it happens.
But you just did your 80th
birthday on stage, right?
- I know, 80.
Can you believe that?
(audience applauds)
- It's, you know what?
It flies by.
You don't feel your age.
- No.
- Yeah.
- No, I don't.
- It's crazy, it's crazy.
- I heard you did something funny
when you came out on stage.
- I did.
(Barry laughs)
I walked out with a walker like this,
(audience laughs)
and then I got to the edge of the stage
and I went, Ta-Da!
It's a miracle.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's amazing.
It is, it is so funny though.
I'm with you though,
I don't feel 41, either.
I don't feel,
- [Barry] 41, you're a
baby compared to this.
- [Kelly] I know, but no,
I'm saying though,
like, when we were kids,
you know, I remember I being 10,
I'd be like, oh, they're almost dead.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like, you're literally in your head.
But like now I'm like,
it doesn't feel that way.
You don't feel, I think you're
as young as you wanna feel.
- You know what the trick is?
I just don't stop.
I just keep going.
There's always another project
and another song and another album.
And I think if you slow
down, you're gonna stop.
And I'm not about to stop.
- [Kelly] Yeah, and why you love it?
- [Barry] Yeah, I love it.
- It's music and you love it.
Yeah.
I agree with you.
Is it true that same stepdad
got you an accordion.
Did he get you an accordion?
Is that your first musical
instrument that you got?
- It was, I'm afraid to say, yes.
- Do you ever play it on stage?
'Cause I really want to see it.
- I do.
I did a little section where I played
'Like a Virgin'.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Barry] Right.
And 'Born in the USA'
and it was just awful.
Just awful.
And it was funny.
- [Kelly] If awful means wonderful.
Yeah, I know.
That's why I love your personality.
You're like this really
incredibly talented guy,
but also very witty.
I heard that your first,
your first job was
actually in the mail room at CBS.
- Yeah.
- Like in the entertainment world.
- I was.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- How did you land that?
That's a random job to land?
- [Barry] I was lucky.
I really, I was lucky.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Barry] Great job.
And I met a lot of great people there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Barry] And I, the first time
I ever played a big grand piano
was in the rehearsal hall at CBS
and suddenly everybody on the floor
and everybody knew that there's
a piano playing mail boy.
(Barry laughs)
And I became the piano
playing mail boy at CBS.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
I love that all those people were like,
that dude used to rock it
like downstairs on this piano.
And then you're Barry Manilow.
That's amazing.
So congratulations.
You opened Harmony on Broadway.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] This has been a long
time in the making, right?
- Yes, yes.
It's been 30 years.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Barry] Yeah.
- We started,
- [Kelly] Labor of Love.
- [Barry] About 30 years ago
and we mounted it a couple of times,
but we just couldn't get it into New York.
But now, we did.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We got it into New York.
- [Kelly] Congratulations.
(Kelly and audience applauds)
- Alright, well we have a review here.
Barry hasn't seen this yet,
but we wanted to show him.
So this expert is from
the New York Stage Review.
Be advised not even to run,
but to race to this tale of a
Six Man Berlin singing group
that was founded in 1927.
That was awesome.
And then we have another one,
the New York Times, which
also listed the musical
as a critic's pick,
said Manilow's vocal arrangements
written with John O'Neill,
the show's music director are marvelous.
I mean, who's shocked at
that news, New York Times.
(applause)
You would be the one
to write incredible arrangements.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's amazing
though, for people to see it
and love it and like get people to go.
- Yes, it's a very, very important
and very deep show and very funny.
- Oh I love, I wouldn't doubt
with you being involved,
this is crazy too.
Did you ever, I heard
this could be a joke,
but did you write into Playboy for advice,
like career advice?
Yeah. And what kind of career
opportunity was one looking
for writing into Playboy?
- I was a desperate young guy.
- Okay, okay.
- Yeah. I didn't know what
to do with my musical life.
And so I saw this thing
in Playboy magazine.
My stepfather, I guess used
to buy it and I sent...
- You just outed him. I like it.
- Yeah, right. So I sent a
letter saying, I have an offer
to go on the road with,
with a girl singer.
I played piano and in
order to do that, I had
to leave my job at CBS as the mail boy.
- Which is steady work.
- Which one should I do?
- Yeah.
- And they, they wrote me
back and they printed it
and they said, take the job outside
and follow your musical notes.
- Oh I love that.
- And I did. I left.
(applause)
- You left and you did it.
- I left CBS.
- So really you have Playboy
to thank for everything.
- I do. No, I do.
- So I know that you and
Bette worked together
quite a bit, so, did she help
you promote your first album?
- Well, yeah, she let me,
I was her music director.
- Yeah
- And the arranger.
And we went on the road together
and I had this first album
and I didn't wanna leave her.
And so she was very generous,
she let me open her second act.
So instead of her coming out, yeah.
The piano player came out
and you know, that was crazy.
The audience didn't wanna see the piano
player singing three songs.
I know that. But again,
they were very kind,
Bette's audiences were very kind to me.
And they let me do three songs
and it was the beginning
of my performing career.
- Wow. I think you're wrong though.
I do think audiences love,
I have my band do that
sometimes. Like come in and out.
I think they do love seeing
artists support other artists.
- Mm.
- `I think that's a big thing.
- Well she was great to let me do that.
- Yeah.
- And then, you know, then
I actually did take off on
my own and here I am.
- I know. And then she was like, crap,
I shouldn't have let him.
I lost my musical director.
- Yeah, right.
- That's amazing. So wait,
- She never forgave me.
- But you, I love it. She's
like, where the hell did you go?
Like, so wait, so no,
I'm sure she's happy,
but like you, I heard that
y'all were at a bathhouse once.
Was it New Year's in the seventies?
- Yeah.
- I need to hear this story
because I heard at one
point you took your suit off.
What happened?
- No. It was called The Continental Baths
and she got booked there
and I was her piano player
and it was a spa for, you know, for guys.
- So people are just running
around naked and your singing.
- Well, they had towels, you know, around
and she would sing the
Star Spangled Banner.
So they would stand up
and the towels would...
- Because she's funny.
- Check out the merchandising. Yeah.
- Yeah. She's perusing
the menu. It's amazing.
- It was a great gig, it was a great gig.
- I heard that they got you to jump in.
Is that true? Did you end up jumping in?
- I did. I jumped. Well they
had a huge pool and it...
- It would be rude not to join.
- Yeah. It was New Year's
Eve. Everybody was happy.
I, you know, I did.
- I have done that as
well at an after party.
I was bored. I was like,
you know, and I was like, this is boring.
So we all jumped in. Me and my band.
- Did you take off your
clothes like I did?
- I did not take off my clothes,
but I didn't have many
on, I was in my twenties.
I didn't have, I think it
was like a crop top anyway.
- Oh. I was still in my suit and tie
and it all went out and I went in.
- I'm kind of a nudist. I don't really,
naked doesn't bother me.
Yeah. Naked doesn't, like
when I went to France
for the first time, I
was so angry I was famous
'cause like I was like, oh,
people are gonna get
pictures so I can't join.
But I thought it would be so
fun. Everyone was just naked.
And I was like, this is
awesome. I was like, yeah.
- Just go on Naked and Afraid.
- I love Naked and afraid.
- Oh my God.
I'm like, what would be your
tool that you would bring?
- Yeah.
- I would bring an axe.
I would bring an Axe, I think.
- Yeah. That's great.
- You get like one thing, right?
Like I haven't watched it in a while
- They give you a bowl, you
know, and a fire starter.
- Hell yeah.
- Those people who can't do the fire..
- Have you ever started a
fire with just, it's hard.
- It's hard.
- Yeah. I would die. Yeah.
Not the best Girl Scout Barry.
So what, let's talk about
the Manilow Music Project.
Let's talk about that.
- Well you know, I did that at,
I started about 15 years
ago when somebody's,
one of my doctors called me
and said, can you get
my daughter a saxophone?
And I said, why? He
said they're running out
of instruments in her high school.
I said, they're running
out of instruments.
Anyway, when I looked it up, yes.
All the high schools
around the country are
running out of instruments.
- They cut the arts programs.
- All the instruments they have are just
old and broken down.
And so I made it my mission to try
to get musical instruments into schools
that are running out of them.
And that's what the
Manilow Music project did.
(applause)
- That's so cool. Especially
like, you and I both get it.
We didn't grow up as much and
I had hand me down everything.
- Yeah.
- You know, you, you kind
of survived off that.
And if you wanted to learn,
if you wanted any opportunity
you needed people to have
you know, readily available
instruments or anything like that.
- These kids are playing
in these, I'm telling you,
broken down instruments
and they still love it.
- Yeah.
- They love their music classes.
- It becomes their second
family. I've met so many.
- I was one of those kids. Yeah.
- Yeah. Somebody, one of the kids sent me
a picture of a tuba that we got him
and the tuba was bigger than he was.
- Which is adorable.
- He was standing next to it. Yeah.
And that's, that's the kind of thing that,
that the Manilow Music Project does.
- Oh, that makes you feel good.
- Yeah, it's good.
- Yeah.
Well go online to find out more about
the Manilow Music Project everybody.
And be sure to watch Barry
Manilow's A Very Barry Christmas
tonight on NBC for Hits
and Christmas songs.